[Music]
[Applause]
In fact there are not many side moves so
you can see I have highlighted by the arrows there are only two
side moves have been tried and especially they are
not good so the first
side move is what I am  Going to have a look is the
bishop to
g5 After bishop to g5 Black should play the
move knight to
e7 and here the main move is to castle on the
king side After words it's a good time to hit this
bishop with the moo a6 and after bishop
to  h4 Black should play the move d6 and can
stabilize his position and it frees the
bishop the game continues with the move rook two but
does not look threatening at all because Black's
piece can come out very very freely so here
I responded with very energetically so
I played the move g5 and after bishop to g3
I played the move bishop to e6 You can see all these
moves are very much forced and after
bishop captures and a capture my opponent
played the move c3 but now there are not many
tricks left so black  Can immediately accept this pun
and after white captures
black can play the move queen to d7 and the
next movement black will castle on the
queen side so for example in this game
my opponent tries to rook to sew but after castle
not on the queen side  Black remains a
clear pawn of V in fact better
position so bishop to g5 dozen queens me at l you can
play against this move very very
confidently The more tricky approach is to castle
on the
kingside so if Black foolishly goes for the a6 then
c3.  Has some enum in these lines where white has
committed c3 and instead he decided to
castle on the kingside I propose that you
delay the development of the g need and play the
move d6 and now c3 dozen create that much hack
in the black cam because  Black can play the moo
queen to f6 hold on to that d pawn and the
planning of the black campaign is very simple
black wants to play knight g2 e7 and then casts
on the king side and asking white why he
has got to sacrifice a pawn so
Again White has to continue with his
initiative so according to his two moves that have been
tried in the first game My opponent tried the move
to e1 but after very
simple bishop to g4 White is having some
problems on the f3 square My opponent
defended with knight  Beat d2 but now I played
the castling on the queen side and the game continues
with the move q to b3 attacking a7 pawn but this can be
successfully made with the following
first black will capture the c3 pawn and after white re captures now
black
plays  The move knight to a4 and this turns
out very very well for white so for example
in the game my opponent played the
move queen to b5 but after very simple knight captures
bishop and queen recapture and knight
to
e7 not only black is clear pun a but  White's
pawn structure on the queen side has been shut so this
line cannot provide any fortune
to the white side in another game My
opponent tried this aggressive looking move that
is the move bishop to g5 but after queen
to g6 still white cannot recapture his  Pun because his
bishop has been protected by the
knight so in the game my opponent tried the
move rook to e1 but now once again I renewed
the threat with the move bishop to g4 so my
opponent has to protect that knight with
another knight so he played  The move knight beats d2 but once again I played our
old
transaction that is d cross s3 so as soon as you see that
knight is coming out it is good
time to capture the pawn after white recaptures
black should play the move at s hitting
the  Bishop Now Please Remember If Queen Comes
To B3 Then Bishop Drop Backs To e6 And
Black Dozen Have Any Problem So In This Game
My Opponent Tried The Move Bishop To H4 But Now
I Played Knight G To e7 And Once Again
If White Can Not Continue  With his
initiative then white will be
a pawn down with a loose pawn
structure so in this game my opponent
tries the move queen to b3 which has a double
attack to the f7 as well as b7 but I completely
played the move b6 and now my opponent  e
Running out of ideas so here he tried
the desperate looking move e5 but here I completely
castle on the king side and now white has no
tricks left
for example if white places e cross
d6 then black can simply recapture with the
bishop and black  Un comes out with the pun
up and instant of e cross d6 The most dangerous
looking move is the
e6 but here black is a wonderful move and
diffuses the whole white attacking idea and
that is the move knight to a5 attacking the two pieces
so the first  The natural response is very obvious
so white is going to capture the a7 with check and
here black's king will go in the corner and after
words white has tried to make
different
moves in the first game my opponent triads
queen to a5 after I capture the bishop nother.  If the
knight captures it it will have a losing
position so for example if the queen captures
c4 then the very simple i knight to f5 attacking
the bishop and after bishop to
g3 the knight captures the bishop pawn captures and the rook
captures
f7 to the queen side of white so white  Has a
shuttered pawn all over on the queen side Black
has a very compact pawn structure as well as the
majority And please do not forget
Black has a bishop pay so it's a dream
position for
Black in the game My opponent goes for this
tricky transaction that  is bishop captures
e7 but after knight captures d2 and bishop
captures f it turns out that black will be
couple of pieces a head after knight takes f3
if the king moves away then black can simply
capture this bishop in the game my opponent
triad g cross f3  But after very simple
bishop captures f3 white king is getting
mated so datchi need to know to diffuse the scotch
gambit you should be thankful to your opponent
for playing such a gambit against you because that
means as a black you get a
clear winning edge starting from  The
Opening I Hope You Enjoy And Learn This
Wonderful Lesson Please Feel Free To Comment On
My Video And I Will Meet You In My
Next Lecture Which Is The Goring Gambit
By